the New York teenager stabbed to death
by alleged gang members has been laid to
rest hundreds of people gathered outside
a Bronx Church yesterday where the
funeral for 15 year old lisandro Guzman
filiz took place his death highlights
the gang violence problem in the
community DeMarco Morgan shows us how
police are using new tools to catch gang
members he's outside the deli where the
teen was attacked
DeMarco good morning good morning to you
the funeral took place at a church that
the family attends about a couple of
blocks away from where we were standing
and there were a number of NYPD officers
and officials in attendance with a young
man who once dreamed of becoming a cop
the family of Guzman family's asset just
feet away from his coffin draped in
white his father and others were Yankees
jerseys in honor of the teens favorite
team during the service clergy had a
message of compassion to the young
people in attendance protect your life
and others today outside hundreds of
supporters called for justice as the
teens casket was loaded into the hearse
hours later six of the eight suspects
arrested in connection with the attack
appeared at a New York courtroom facing
murder manslaughter and gang assault
charges the suspects are alleged members
of the trinitarios gang she's a ruthless
violent gang the NYPD also announced
yesterday a crackdown on a different
Bronx gang known as the Mack ballers 20
people face charges ranging from
racketeering to murder in both cases the
police used social media to help track
down the suspects much of that work is
down here at the NYPD's real time crime
Center teams of investigators stick
through social media platforms after a
crime is committed looking for clues
tips and evidence Dermot Shay is the
NYPD's Chief of Detectives
we see in the case of violent street
gangs frequently they're bragging about
what they're doing so social media is
has perfect to be an invaluable tool and
for people worried about being seen
talking to authorities Shea says social
media lets them safely share information
with police we have to have trust with
the community and the power of unity
here so the community and the police
together common cause we will not be
defeated by that small number of people
outside from tracking criminals social
media is crucial when it comes to
getting tips chief Shea says the video
that was actually posted over the attack
on Guzman Philly is when it was posted
on social media tips started pouring in
and it allowed them to make arrests
quickly very quickly indeed DeMarco
thank you